el hecho de que esa sea la primera
visita de Nicolás maduro Brasil tras
ocho años Fue muy remarcado por ambos
mandatarios para quienes esto se puede
considerar como el inicio de un cambio
en las relaciones entre Venezuela y
Brasil el presidente lulo da Silva y
Nicolás Maduro tuvieron una serie de
compromisos en Brasil en el Palacio de
plana auto que se concluyó con una rueda
de prensa el presidente de Brasil Lula
agradeció la oportunidad dijo que era
una alegría recibir a Nicolás Maduro en
Brasil y dijo que Brasil y Venezuela hoy
tienen lo que él considera como pequeños
problemas de orden económico y político
y insto y esto el presidente Nicolás
Maduro ha contribuir para que las
relaciones entre ambos países no sean
solo en el orden comercial el presidente
venezolano agradeció la atención del
gobierno brasileño dijo que tuvo una
buena conversación con Lula da Silva y
lamentó la pérdida de las relaciones en
los últimos años por lo que llamó de
ideologización de la política en
Sudamérica
el presidente Nicolás Maduro dijo que
tras el cierre de puertas y ventanas por
Brasil las relaciones se restablecen de
forma franca con un diálogo abierto No
solo con Brasil pero con todos los
países de la región el presidente
Nicolás Maduro está en Brasilia para
participar
de la Cumbre que va a reunir 11
presidentes y representantes de países
de la región además de Brasil a partir
de mañana martes la intención del
gobierno de Lulu da Silva es relanzar la
unión de países sudamericanos la unasur